very quickly with the training we
will clarify the supply routes very quickly
and I think that the first
Leopard tanks could be in the Ukraine in about 3 months.
For me that was
central from the start because it is not
about delivering any war equipment or
any weapon  but one
of the best battle tanks that is in the
world that is an important an
important game changer possibly
also in this war, at least in the
current war phase
these are not decisions that a
member country alone makes,
in particular none that rightly claims for itself
and also from it  there is a demand
to be leading nations,
because claiming leadership and
exercising leadership does not mean
looking blindly ahead, marching forward,
but also
taking those who have to go along and
support you with you, and that’s why he did
that, the chancellor did that
in his talks and that  The result,
even though it may have taken longer
than one or the other would have
liked subjectively, gives him
100% account, that's why
I'm very happy that everyone is on the boat, there
are many citizens in this country and
citizens who are concerned
about such a decision
and in view of the dimensions that this
weapon entails and that is why
I would like to say to these citizens here and
at this point, trust me, trust
the Federal Government, we
will continue to
ensure that
this support is possible without
the risks for  our country is
growing in the wrong direction over it that's
why we're doing this and that's how we're going to
continue
That has
n't been the case so far and it wo
n't be the case in the future either. Everyone
can rely on that. That's what I
said right from the start, not only by
me but also by the American
President, and together that should probably
be an important word
[applause  ]